the great races members were immense
rugose cones ten feet high and of head
and other organs attach two-foot thick
distend herbal limbs spread in from the
apex 'as they spoke by the clicking or
scraping of huge paws or claws attached
to the end of two of their four limbs
and walked by the expansion and
contraction of a viscous layer attached
to their vast ten-foot bases there is no
doubt that the world created by Howard
Phillips Lovecraft is full of mysterious
creatures and entities and there is just
so many that we can discuss last week we
discussed the underwater race known as
the deep ones and this week it is the
great race of year the quote that I read
at the start of the videos from the
story the shadow out of time if you're
not an expert in alien races or the work
of Lovecraft then there's a good chance
you read that like I did and thought
Howard what the hell are you talking
about this time so what exactly are the
great race of year what to start we know
that they're an alien race that came
from the planet yes so no surprises
there
there isn't much said about their
original form or appearance but we do
know that they had the extremely useful
skill of being able to project their
consciousness across time and space
making them capable of swapping bodies
of other species this process was used
by the year as a way of gathering
knowledge and experience in the life of
other species while the hosts will
experience the life of the year when
this process was finished the memories
of the hosts will be completely wiped
but some would selects perience these
memories through vivid dreams and
nightmares just so we don't have to keep
calling them the great race of year this
entire video they were also refer to as
the youth and the youth Ian's so the
youth Ian's would eventually end up
fleeing their home planet and end up
swapping bodies with a primitive species
living on earth they then continued to
grow and acquire knowledge for millions
of years until they felt confident
enough to go to war with the other
species living on our planet the fine
polyps and the elder things they would
eventually best the flying polyps by
trapping them under the Earth's surface
however in their great hindsight the
youth saw that the flying polyps were
returned one day in destroy them so they
switch minds and bodies with a race of
primitive beetles that was set to out
lost humanity the thien's built their
own city deep under the desert of
Australia which would house their many
manuscripts detail in the long history
and all of the knowledge they acquired
so to get the details we can look at La
Crosse story the shadow out of time
which was published in June 1936 and
tells a story of the great race of year
here the earth Ian's are described as
originally being a peaceful
species whose purpose was to study the
history of the universe at various times
and places they were essentially
creating this library city full of the
past and future history of dozens of
different species it's never really
explained in any detail as to why they
fled their home planet but it is hinted
that they were the beings of a die-in
elder world they would then arrive on
earth and take the body of a weird
cone-shaped species which had four
strange appendages capable of extending
and retracting large distances two of
these appendages had claws attached
which were used as a way of
communicating through an elaborate
series of clicking which does raise an
interesting question as to whether this
form of clicking was used as a way to
communicate with each other or other
species because they clearly have
telepathic powers but maybe they don't
stretch as far as being able to
communicate with their own species in
this way the third appendage was a
yellow globe three eyes and flower-like
ears which we can assume might have
acted as some kind of head
the last appendage is described as being
four red trumpets and I'm not exactly
sure what they're meant to be the youth
are described as having no sexes and
they were said to reproduce through the
distribution of spores but because of
the species longevity reproduction
didn't occur as often as other species
the shadow out of time is told from the
perspective of Nathaniel Wingate peasley
who was possessed by a a thean because
of the link between the two Nathaniel
share some of the knowledge collected by
the Athene's and starts to see other
worlds and experiences what it's like to
be an alien species when he returns to
his own body those around him believe
him to be insane and Nathaniel is
inclined to agree
believing that the dreams he's
experienced in our sign of mental
illness the dreams become more and more
vivid over time and after doing some
research Nathaniel finds out there are
others just like him report in similar
cases these dreams soon become an
obsession as he searches for the ancient
manuscripts that would help prove that
he is an insane eventually he discovers
the earth Ian's died out a long time ago
destroyed by a rival alien race
described as half poly pest creatures
the Athene's would eventually return
with new bodies but only long after
humanity had ceased to exist now faced
with the proof and answers that he
desired Nathaniel was no better off than
he was before he may have found evidence
of the Earth's existence but with that
comes a realization that the species
that destroyed them still inhabits our
planet the story is interesting because
it covers mental illness at a time where
you could be classified as insane for
the tiniest of things
never mind talking about the existence
of numerous alien species the
also several topics and questions raised
by this story such as what came before
us and what will exist once were gone I
know for me personally seen how weird
the earth Ian's look in this earthly
adapted form
my biggest question would probably be
what the hell did they look like before
I do really like the concept of this
librarian alien race that collects
information on other species because it
creates this interesting dynamic of what
would happen if this information fell
into the wrong hands and this notion of
various cults searching for these
manuscripts in the Earth's ancient city
is something that I've seen many people
discussing let me know what you guys and
girls think about the great race of
youth in the comments below especially
if you have any theories and what you
think they may have looked like as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]